[Music]
yeah this is Hill this this is going to
destroy the ability of good people to
come forward because of this crap to my
Republican colleagues if you vote no
you're legitimizing the most despicable
thing I have seen in my time in politics
you want this seat I hope you never get
it I hope you're on the Supreme Court
that's exactly where you should be and I
hope that the American people will see
through this charade Senator Lindsey
Graham South Carolina one of the most
powerful moments of Supreme Court
justice Brett Kavanaugh is confirmation
hearings last year well the left is
still not done smearing justice
Cavanaugh he joins us now he is the
Senate Judiciary Committee chairman that
was what listen I've known you a long
time I think that was your finest moment
and you got a lot of good moments over
your career thank you but you now see it
doesn't stop and even dick Durbin said
this idea of impeaching this what is
your reaction to the times because it's
no different than what happened that day
then you spoke up well when you think
you you've hit bottom you really haven't
when it comes to Trump it's not really
news that the New York Times did a
sloppy job reporting about Trump and
Cavanaugh because they're so biased but
what what is news to me is that two
United States senators running for
president have called for a Cavanaugh's
impeachment based on an article The New
York Times this bogus and a member of
the House has introduced an impeachment
resolution of Judge Cavanaugh based on a
erroneous scurrilous New York Times
story so here's why I want you to know
any impeachment of judge Cavanaugh based
on the New York Times story is dead on
arrival in the Senate Indian Pietschmann
of President Trump based on the Muller
report is dead on arrival in the United
States Senate well let me ask you
because this doubt dovetails into other
issues yeah journalism is dead I yeah I
expect this now the New York Times they
have no credibility I it's not even
worth the paper it's printed on this
point and actually the iron is they need
Donald Trump more than he needs them
probably which is interesting but you
know I get a little antsy waiting for
this Inspector General report senator
get a little antsy whether or not
they're going to conclude what I know to
be true and that is that those for
Pfizer application warrants were full of
lies that they were warned about missus
it Russian lies that Hillary paid for
the bulk of information a famous memo
was put out has your name on it and what
I'm concerned about I want to here in no
uncertain terms those warrants were
illegally obtained do you think I'm
likely to hear that you know I really
don't know Horowitz did a good job I
think when it came to the Clinton email
investigation he's not a prosecutor he
doesn't have the ability to subpoena and
interview witnesses outside of DOJ or
the FBI but here's what I do believe I
do believe the warrant process was
abused and not only do I hope he will
tell us that it was off the rails
I hope the FISA Court will take the
report seriously I'm looking for the
FISA Court to clean this mess up if the
court doesn't take corrective action why
should we trust the court in the future
I'm looking for Durham to hold these
people accountable if they did in fact
take the law in their own hands I'm not
looking to prosecute somebody because I
don't like them I'm this never happens'
brain here if you warned ahead of time
that dossier is Hillary and she paid for
it and then the guy that authored it
hates Trump and you're also warned that
it's not verified not once but on
probably at least four and I have a
source telling me five or six times they
will warn that is premeditated then if
you didn't take the time to verify it
yourself now we know it's unverifiable
then the FBI when they finally got
around to verifying it after some of the
warrants were already issued they
determined it wasn't a truth none of
this was true so that means that a
premeditated fraud on a court for the
purpose of spying on an individual
denying that individual their rights
quarter-page but then it's a it's an
open door into all things Trump campaign
tree
and presidency now you're the lawyer
does that what I just described sound
like crimes to you well it sounds
horrible if we legitimize this then god
help us all if we legitimize the fact
it's not the question of justice and I
try to be a pain in the neck but is that
does that not sound if you if I commit
if I go before my court and I lie and I
was told at a time what you're telling
us is a crime yes it's clearly a crime
if you look we'll give false information
to the court but I'm not a prosecutor
Horowitz is not a prosecutor we're going
to leave that up to Durham but here's
what I want you to know every American
should be concerned about the fact that
the Department of Justice and the FBI
knew that the source of the document had
a bias and they did nothing to ensure
the document was reliable is not
reliable to this day and if the court
doesn't clear this up and take
corrective action then why do you expect
people in the future to be deterred if
somebody doesn't go to jail and if the
court doesn't hold those who lied to the
court accountable then we will have
missed a great opportunity to restore
the rule of law well know that I will
tell you I take it a step further I
think we just might as well shred the
Constitution because that means we will
be a bad day for America to let this
crap go underdressed
last question legal question if you your
committee subpoenaed my emails and I
decide I'm gonna delete happen and then
I bring in some computer expert that
tells me how to clean my hard drive why
pickle it's like bleaching it out and
then I have an aide of mine bust up my
phones and blackberries and remove the
SIM cards would you think I'm committing
obstruction of justice of the committee
and their investigation and number two
do you think I would not be charged in
that case because I kind of believe I
would but I'm not a lawyer well the
first thing if you're at home don't try
this because it will not work out well
the bottom line is if there's no
consequences to taking a hammer to a
device being asked for by Congress and
bleaching out information Congress wants
then what's the downside to lyin to
Congress
and obstructing justice when it comes to
Congress this is a very big deal I have
a lot of faith in Horowitz I have a lot
of faith in Durham a lot of faith in Bar
all right and I sure as hell have a lot
of faith in me we're gonna do a lot of
guys work very fast I mean I work 16
hours 17 hours a day and I'm like
where's the stupid report by this time
I'm I'm getting a little impatient here
I'm not worried about when it comes out
I'm worried about what's in it when it
does all right I know you'll do the
right thing senator thank you